our subject accept the gift
accept the gift
after this there was a feast of the jews
and jesus went up to jerusalem
now there is a jerusalem by the sheep
market a pool
which is called in the hebrew town
bethesda
having five porches
in these lay a great multitude of
impotent folk of blind halt withered
waiting for the moving of the water for
an angel went down at the certain season
into the pool and troubled the water
whosoever then first after the troubling
of the water stepped in was made whole
of whatsoever disease he had
and a certain man was there which had an
infirmity eight thirty and eight years
when jesus saw him lie and knew he had
been now a long time in that case
he says unto him
will thou be made whole the impotent man
answered him sir
i have no man when the water is troubled
to put me into the pool
but while i am coming another steppeth
down before me
jesus saith unto him rise take up thy
bed
and walk
and immediately the man was made whole
and took up his bed and walked and on
the same day was a sabbath
the jews therefore said unto him that
was cured it is the sabbath day it is
not lawful for thee to carry thy bed
he answered them
he that made me whole the same said unto
me take up thy bed and walk
then ask the him what man is that which
said unto thee take up thy bed and walk
and he that was healed whisked not who
it was for jesus had conveyed himself
away a multitude being in that place
afterward
jesus findeth him in the temple and said
unto him
behold thou art made whole
sin no more
lest the worst thing come unto thee
god is good
and all the time let's try that again
and all the time
psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is good
his mercy is everlasting
and his truth endureth
to all generations
i thank god for preserving the breath of
life in my nostrils i'm really grateful
to him i believe in exercise and
nutrition and all of that yes i do with
all my heart and soul but i'm kept alive
by the mercies of god are you following
me keep taking your vitamin e and doing
your push-ups and your sit-ups but
always remember it is by the grace of
god that you and i are still alive today
and so i thank god for life i thank him
for this glorious privilege of
addressing you on the subject of the
word of god and my prayer is that god
will put his words in my mouth and give
you comprehension so that the truth
heard understood will be applied
truth has no effect if it is not
received into the heart and applied to
the life by the invited spirit the
spirit does not force his way and cause
someone to obey we must be willing
thank you very much for coming is there
anyone with us tonight for the first
time i see my good brother
first time he and i were at school long
before you were born
long time ago
nice to see you carry god bless you
we'll talk a little later anyone else
you're with us for the first time anyone
else first time first time don't be
afraid we're nice people anyone else
first time first time all right well let
us get down to the message it is 6 34
and i will let you out by 7 15. but
before i get into the subject please as
always i ask you to do three favors what
is favor number one
well right turn off whatever you don't
need
as it's amazing how phones in our bibles
but anyway that's a different story if
you don't need yours make sure it's off
so it does not ring in the presence of
god in other words preserve reverence
and the lord will be pleased favor
number two what is that
pray for me what should you say lord
[Laughter]
i love that man he's handsome man
yes that's true lord slow down that man
and put your words in his mouth i thank
you i really do doctor peter you're a
good man all right was uh uh jeremiah 1
verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touch my mouth isn't that a
privilege
and that touches not to destroy
it is to enable you to say what's right
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth it's a
tremendous honor to have god directly
put his words in your mouth
and favor number three
what is that
think isaiah 1 18 what does that say
come now let us do what reason together
saith the lord and as i told you on
previous occasions we serve a reasonable
god
satan
is unreasonable
god
is reasonable let's pray
father
we come in the name of jesus a name you
never resist
a name that has all power in heaven and
in earth
a name that's equal to yours
we come in his name and we thank you for
sparing our lives
we thank you to god for freedom of
worship which we still enjoy in this
country
as we bow before you father look deep
into our hearts if there's anything you
see you do not like
remove it there god we grant you full
and free permission
washes make us clean because the
presence of sin interferes with our
ability to understand truth
i humble myself before you and i ask you
earnestly the god speak through me tell
me what to say when and how
fill me with your spirit and place the
humility of christ in my heart
anyone listening to me is sick bring
healing to that person father bring
significant relief and if anyone has
coveted 19 remove that affliction
completely their god
be merciful to those in ukraine they're
now under war bullets flying bombs
exploding their god we have no idea what
that is like be merciful father
particularly to those in that country
who are of the house of faith
nowaday god direct me that your name may
be glorified and you'll bless your
beloved people blessed in jesus name i
pray let god's people say amen and amen
go with me to luke
chapter
luke 19.
you know i don't have one yet
i'll think of one as i'm going through
the message i don't have one yet
look
19 but a good question dr peter good
question luke 19.
do you have that in that chapter jesus
christ has a meeting with a man called
zacchaeus he was not very tall he
climbed into a tree to see christ as he
passed by christ looked up told him come
down quickly he wanted to go to his
house he came down went to his house
and in verse 10
of luke 19 here is what jesus said
for the son of man is come to do two
things what is that
seek
and to save that which was lost now if
christ came to do that it is because we
cannot do that
a sinner cannot of his own volition or
hers go to christ
there must be movement from heaven to
move that person and of course the
person must cooperate with the
convicting force of the spirit of god
let me say again if christ came to seek
and to save it is because you and i
cannot do that for ourselves
let's go to john chapter 10.
the very next book john 10.
we read verse 10.
it's a familiar verse
the thief cometh not but for to do what
steal to kill and to destroy
finish that verse i am come that they
might have life and they might have it
more abundantly which means christ came
to dead people
what did he come to bring
life then to whom did he come dead
people
go to ephesians chapter two let's read
from verse one
our subject accept the gift
accept the gift
ephesians chapter 2 reading verse 1.
do you have that
read with me and you hath he quickened
who were dead in trespasses and sins to
quicken is to bring alive you
hath he quickened who were dead in
trespasses and says now you tell me what
can a dead man do for himself nothing
he does not even control the process of
decomposition
a dead man
can do nothing
for himself he needs help from the
outside when lazarus died jesus christ
raised him because lazarus could not
raise himself let me apply that
spiritually there is no sinner who can
save himself or herself you simply
cannot do it
if you could there would have been no
need for calvary
let me say it again with great respect i
speak to you and to me no human being
can save himself or herself salvation is
the work of god and god alone
when i say god alone yes god requires
our cooperation but the act of removing
sin is the work of god the act of
justifying someone is the work of god
which means
everyone born into this world
needs god
adam wasn't born into the world he was
made into it but because of sin he had
a more intense need for god he needed
someone to save him a sinner cannot save
himself which means a sinner needs a
savior can you say amen to that a sinner
needs a savior now the sinner's
condition is so horrific the sinner does
not even go in search of a savior
go to romans 3
romans chapter 3 we read from verse 10
our subject except the gift is 6 42.
when did i say i'd let you go
i may have to modify my phraseology
and let you go beyond that we'll see how
the holy spirit moves what book did i
say
what chapter three reading from what
first
read with me but as it is written come
on
there is none righteous no not one keep
reading there is none that
there is none that
yes
no sinner goes looking for god
now many sinners go looking for church
those are not the same things now
they're related if it's the right church
are you following me but you can seek a
church and not seek god
there is none that understandeth unaided
the christian the sinner sorry cannot
understand the plan of salvation to a
degree that will allow him or her to go
after the savior or to call upon the
savior there is none that understandeth
there is none that seeketh after god
there's none that doeth good no not one
now when the bible says that there's
none that doeth good as good is defined
by god
matthew 7
some people say to god or will say to
god in the judgment lord lord have we
not what
prophesied in thy name and in thy name
have cast out devils and in thy name
than many wonderful works those things
are good in quotation marks when done
outside of the power of god they are not
good in the eyes of god jesus christ is
clear in john 15 without me finish it
he can do nothing
all right
let me stop embarrassing the sinner
go with me to matthew 11.
matthew 11 our subject accept the gift
matthew 11.
you have that
we read from verse 28 these are the
words of christ
matthew 11 reading from verse 28.
read with me if you have my version come
unto me
only that labor and a heavy laden and i
will give you rest question for you
you've got one chance to get the answer
right what is the heaviest burden you
and i can carry one word three letters
sin
now go to isaiah 45.
isaiah is called the gospel prophet he
speaks so much about christ
and chapter 53 is the number one chapter
in the old testament that speaks about
christ there's psalm 69 psalm 22 but
isaiah 53 is the preeminent chapter
about christ eloise said read that every
day it will have a humbling effect on
you
what book did i say isaiah what chapter
45 what verse 22.
isaiah 45 verse 22
thank you
read with me look unto me come on
and be saved all the ends of the earth
for i am god and there is none else
jesus says look to me
that's before he came to the earth when
he was on the earth he said come to me
go to john chapter 5
john 5.
john chapter 5
john is a beautiful
gospel read it sometime
all 21 chap beautiful beautiful it's
written by the disciple who is closest
to christ
so you're getting something of an inside
view of jesus that's why the gospel of
john is not a synoptic gospel matthew
mark and luke those three are called
synoptic gospels because they tend to
see things similarly john has such a
different approach his is not a synoptic
gospel he has a different approach about
jesus john chapter 5 verse 40 what
complaint does christ utter in that
verse
tell me
and you will not come to me king james
version that you might have what life
go to first john chapter five
excuse me first john chapter 5.
i hope you don't mind me sending you
back and forth to the bible
but i want you to understand i'm using
god's words not mine
you have first john chapter five
read verse 11 what is that saying
and this is the record that god has
given to us what eternal life and this
life is in his son read verse 12 that
entire verse is made up of monosyllabic
words read verse 12 for me he that hath
the son come on hath life he that hath
not the son
every word one syllable
one of the simplest verses in the bible
to read each verse one syllable yet the
meaning is oceanic in its significance
it's profound he that hath the son hath
life and he that hath not the son hath
not life meaning the life that saves
is not simply in jesus how should i say
it the life that saves
jesus says
i am life i am truth i'm the way the
life that saves yes it's in jesus but it
is more accurate to say the life that
saves is jesus
because he is
life what did he say to martha
by lazarus's tomb
i am the resurrection
and the life
all right
having said that let's go now to luke 18
we'll read from verse 9
but let me pray again fathers i continue
to speak to your people speak through me
then what i say to them may be words
from your throne of truth in jesus name
i pray amen
luke 18 we'll read from verse 9 our
subject accept the gift
are you there
and he spake this parable unto certain
that trusted in themselves that they
were righteous and what despise others
true righteousness does not lead to
despising sinners it leads to a soft
heart for the sinner
they thought they were righteous they
despise others two men went up into the
temple to pray the one a pharisee and
the other republican verse 11 the
pharisees stood and prayed thus with
himself god i thank thee that i am not
as other men are
that's a catastrophic mistake to make
let us not make it comparing ourselves
spiritually to other people
i think they i am not as other men are
extortioners unjust adulterers or even
as this publican
and now he advertises his qualifications
for heaven i fast twice in the week
i do what
give tithes of all that i possess
those are good works in quotation marks
listen to the publican
in verse 13 and republican
standing afar off would not lift up so
much as his eyes unto heaven but smote
upon his breasts saying what god
be merciful to me a sinner
when someone asks for mercy in what
condition is that person
humble what else
if you're walking down a dark alley
and someone puts a shotgun to your head
and asks for your wallet and said blow
your head off whether you give it to me
or not
and you ask for mercy why
what position are you in
you know what
oh you're in danger in a vulnerable
position you're in a position of help
less-ness
and so you need
mercy
you don't turn to the guy with a shotgun
and say listen i'll give you a break
walk away no you don't do that
he gives you a break
that shows mercy the sinner is in that
situation because the law is the shotgun
because the wages of sin come on is
death it's not because the law is bad
the law is love but sin has to be dealt
with and the law of love declares death
to be the penalty for sin
because sin is an attack on god and his
government
mercy
republicans said god
be
do for me what i can't do for myself be
merciful to me
he acknowledges god
the only one who can save him
and his wretched condition
i am a sinner there's nothing good in me
that i can offer you as raw materials to
make a saint out of me i'm just no good
be merciful here i am which means
we must come to god
with all our sins
you don't improve yourself and then come
to god
that's god's work
are you following me
you come to god with the cigarette in
your mouth
you come to god with the marijuana in
your pocket you come to god with the
call 45 in your back pocket that's how
you come to god you don't have to dress
in a suit you come to god
but i'll tell you something about coming
to god because we read in romans 3 verse
11 there's none the secret after god go
to john 6 44 and see how good god is our
subject accept the gift
john 6
44. do you have it
that amen says you have the book now do
you have 6
and 44.
let's read that verse carefully what
does that say
no man
can come to me
except the father which have sent me
draw him and i will raise him up at the
last day let's read that again this time
microscopically
no one
can come to god
unless god exerts a pulling force
even coming to god requires help from
god
because god wants to save
no man
can come to god
except the father which have sent me
draw him
go to verse 65
of the same chapter john the same
sentiment is repeated with a slight
difference in the wording
read for me what does that say
and he said unto them therefore said i
unto you that no man can come to me
except it were given to him of my father
it is god through the spirit that puts
upon the heart of a man or a woman to
come but the person has to yield to that
pleading from god
now go to ephesians 6
not 6 or 8 romans 6.
well you know it you don't have to go
there the wages of sin
is death finish the verse
but the gift of god is eternal life now
the gift of god and what's our subject
accept the gift listen to me salvation
is a gift
when you have a gift two actions take
place
it is given
and received
offered
it must be received
the wages of sin
death
wages are what you deserve
are you with me
a gift is the outpouring of a generous
heart
the wages of sin
death
the gift of god eternal life now let's
take a look at that let's go to
leviticus chapter one we'll read from
verse one our subject is what except the
gift is 654.
do you have leviticus one
and i told you last night i believe it
was the key word in leviticus is
holiness
leviticus one reading from verse one
let me pray again father continue to be
with me i ask you i plead with you i
appeal to you in jesus name amen
and the lord called unto moses
and spake unto him out of the tabernacle
of the congregation saying
speak unto the children of israel and
say unto them if any man if you bring an
offering to the lord he shall bring your
offering of the cattle out of the herd
of the flock now
if his offering be a burnt sacrifice of
the herd let him offer a male without
blemish stop
we have two beings in that verse
identify the two beings in verse three
the what
the sacrifice and
and the sinner bringing the sacrifice if
his
if the burnt offering of his sacrifice
be of the herd let him offer a male so
we have the sacrifice and we have the
sinner
which one is described
the sacrifice how was it described
without blemish
without spot
yes without blemish but spot as well
let him offer a male without blemish
is the sinner described
no now that does not mean god endorses
sin
in salvation the key thing is not the
condition of the sinner
but the condition
of the savior
it matters more to god who jesus is
than who you are
now
here comes the sinner with the sacrifice
the priest has to examine that animal
he does not examine the person who
brought it
again that's not to say god endorses sin
he doesn't but you need to understand
the focus of salvation is the savior the
condition the sinless state of the
savior jesus christ the priest examines
the animal not the person who brought
the animal
as a matter of fact the person brings
the animal because the person is
spiritually dirty and unclean so that's
a take that's a given
he comes unclean
and he brings a clean sacrifice
read verse 4
of vegas one and he shall do what
upon the head of the what burnt offering
and it shall be accepted for him to make
atonement for him let's look at that
carefully and he shall place or lay his
hand upon the head of the burnt offering
or the birth sacrifice
that symbolizes transfer
of sins
it shall be accepted
for him
let me truly slow down you have to get
this what is accepted for him
the animal is accepted
in his place
to make atonement
for him
because he
cannot make it
are you following me
the sinner cannot atone for his sins
and so the animal is accepted for him in
his place
the focus of salvation
is the savior
and what he is able to do for us
when that sinner places his hand on the
head
of the burnt sacrifice the burnt
offering and confesses his sins there is
symbolically a transfer of sin from the
sinner to the animal of course the
sinner has to understand that symbolizes
christ no animal can save you are you
with me it symbolizes the messiah to
come
he walks away
clean
forgiven
are you following me
all his sins now are on that animal
the animal is killed
and he has to kill him
read verse 5
and he shall
kill the what
the bullock
before the lord and the priest
aaron's son shall bring the blood and
sprinkle the blood round about the wall
altar which is where
tabernacle
the priest takes the blood but the
sinner
kills the animal
the sinner has the sin the animal is
without blemish
the sinner kills the animal why did
christ die because
of sin
and then the sinner leaves forgiven
and this animal now
with all the sins transferred to it is
killed the blood is taken by the priest
and the priest takes it inside and
applies it and goes with that ritual
what i want you to see is this
that animal
is accepted in place of the sinner
what does that mean
it is only the righteousness of jesus
christ
that can save you or me
not how many offices we've held in the
church but keep your offices don't go
resigning tomorrow it is not how much
money we have given we need to
understand i am saved by the
righteousness of jesus christ covering
me
the same way the priest examines the
animal
in the judgment
god looks at your savior
of course if you don't have one then
you're up a creek without a paddle god
examines the savior and the savior in
the sense that he looks at the covering
that you have it is the covering of
jesus christ it is the righteousness of
christ and the righteousness of christ
has no sin which means when you truly
give the life to christ god looks at you
as if what
[Music]
you never sinned
now you tell me
and then he offers that gift to you here
here's my righteousness it's a gift
my righteous life you see christ came
live the life that god has always wanted
the israelites never did it so christ
came he lived the life the father wants
and then he go he offers that life to
you
here's a life
that will be placed to your account
if you surrender to me
here you are oh here am i
i travel a lot i'm always in airports
going through security
here i am with the president of the
united states
he and i walking together
which security guard will search me
are you with me
the president says he is
with me
i just go with the president i don't
even go through security
why
because i am covered come on by the
prison
but i can't be in ohio while the
president is in cleveland are you
following me
we have to be at the same place at the
same time so that he who he is can cover
me when i'm with him i go through
security no one touches me i don't even
go through i just go because the
president is not searched diplomatic
bags are not searched they're covered
you go to heaven
the only way to do that
is to go with christ
but not with christ standing next to you
with christ
within you
so that the life of christ
becomes my life
let me not let me say that again the
life of christ
becomes my life
literally
paul had that experience what did paul
say i am crucified with christ
nevertheless
i live
yet not i
but christ liveth in me
this is what god wants to do for us
this is the gift the gift he has is the
gift of the righteous victorious sin
free life of jesus christ and there's
something called justification that's
what that public can receive when you
went down to his house there's a first
we did not read luke 18 verse 14 jesus
said i tell you this man went down to
his house justified rather than the
other what is christ saying he left
right with god because he left covered
by the blood of jesus christ in that
parable that christ told
when adam and eve sinned go with me to
genesis chapter 3
just about 705
we have time
genesis 3.
our subject accept the gift
we read from verse 7.
adam has sinned eve for sin well let's
let's make it chronological correct evil
sin adam followed suit now in verse
seven
the bible says in the eyes of them both
were opened
and they knew that they were naked
and they saw fig leaves together
and made themselves aprons they knew
that something was wrong but they could
do nothing about it
they saw fig leaves
they made the fig leaves not god
observe with me verse 7 of genesis 3.
i want you to read that verse quietly
and tell me who are mentioned in that
verse
we haven't got all night come on answer
adam and eve who's missing
god
what are they doing trying to respond to
their sins are you following me god is
not involved in what happened in the
creation of aprons made from leaves and
leaves do not bleed now go to verse 21
read it out loud my king james people
unto adam also and to his wife did the
lord god make coats of skins and clothe
them now you tell me who are mentioned
in verse 21
adam
eve come on and god
but observe the activity in verse 7 and
the eyes of them both were opened and
they knew that they were naked and they
sowed fig leaves together and made
themselves they clothed themselves we
don't need help from god to sin
sin is what we do in our own satanic
power
but verse 21
unto adam also
and to his wife did the lord god make
coats of skins come on
and clothe them
the righteousness you and i need to be
saved as eloise says is woven in the
loom of
in heaven 21
the making of the garments the work of
god
clothing them
the work of god but of course they had
to allow god to do that that is
surrender
god gave him the gift
those
courts represented
the righteousness of jesus christ the
only way
anyone can be saved let's see this exact
process expressed differently in the
book of zechariah reading from
chapter three reading verse one
zechariah chapter three reading from
verse one our subject accept the gift
it's a free gift
zechariah chapter 3 reading from verse 1
are you there
if you have my version read with me and
he showed me joshua the high priest
standing before the angel of the lord
and satan standing at his right hand to
resist him and the lord said unto satan
the lord rebuked thee o satan even the
law that have chosen jerusalem rebuke
thee is not this a brand plucked out of
the fire now read verse 3 carefully what
does that say now joshua's clothed what
with filthy garments and stood before
the angel stop
adam and eve were clothed in filthy
aprons
no difference
now joshua who represents the israelite
was clothed with filthy remnants and
stood before the angel and he answered
them speaking to those that stood before
him saying what
take away the filthy garments from him
and unto him he said what
behold i have caused thine iniquity pass
from thee and i will close thee with
change of raymond i will do that
listen to this passage
now the lord has said unto abram
get thee out of thy country
and from thy kindred and from thy
father's house unto a land that i will
show thee and i will make of thee a
great nation and i will bless thee and i
will make thy name great and thou shalt
be a blessing and i will bless them that
bless thee and i will curse them that
curse it is i i i will do everything all
you've got to do is do what i tell you
leave all the rest of the work to me
it's a gift
but you and i must understand
i cannot
save myself
as i said last night i believe it was so
today
i can live a decent life
i can avoid getting traffic tickets
i can avoid being audited by the irs
i can avoid all kinds of things and
never see the inside of a courtroom
does not qualify me for heaven because
jesus says likewise also as it was in
the days of lot they did they trying
they bought they sold they planted they
build it which of those is a crime
none
lost it is only the righteous life of
christ but when that life is received by
faith life is not something that sleeps
are you following me life is expressive
life is active and if the life of christ
is in me
it is lived out in me
let's go to two verses that express it
differently
philippians chapter two verse five then
i'll bring you to close philippians
chapter 2 verse 5.
you know that very well but let's find
it
and read it
philippians 2 verse 5. what does that
verse say
let this mind be in you which was also
in christ jesus stop
the verse does not call us to get a mind
similar
to the mind of christ
it will produce a life
similar to the mind of christ which
means we'll have two lives competing for
qualification for heaven the life of
christ and one similar
only the life of christ
can qualify us for salvation now
therefore when paul says let this mind
be in you which was also in christ jesus
the jesus who walked this earth that's
precisely the mind you and i must have
and he or she who has that mind will
live out the life of christ
go to hebrews chapter 12
accept the gift hebrews 12.
this week from verse 10
those of you with my version read with
me what does that say
for their verily for a few days chasing
us after the what
but he for our
that we might be partakers of his
yes
not a holiness that resembles it
we must reflect the holiness of god
insofar as a created being can reflect
it the verse doesn't call us to be god
it calls us to be like god and so
philippians 2 verse 5 have the mind of
god hebrews 12 verse 10 express the
holiness of god go to second peter
chapter 1 verse 4.
second peter chapter one reading verse
four
do we have that
read for me
whereby are given unto us what exceeding
great and precious promises that by
these readon
he might be partakers of what the divine
nature stop what do we have
we must partake
of the divine nature we must partake of
the holiness of god we must have the
mind of christ
without those
there's no victory over sin
the power of sin
is the power of satan
and when christ created satan who was
lucifer he created the most powerful
being he had ever created
no other angel was as powerful as
lucifer
when lucifer was thrown out because he
rebelled he lost his position he did not
lose his power
when you're dealing with satan you're
dealing with the power that only the
power of god can conquer
you need the mind of christ
partake of the nature
and the holiness of god
and they're all offered to us
as a gift
in jesus christ
look unto me
and be saved all the ends of the earth
for those of you listening to me live
whoever listens to this recording
stop looking at how bad you are yes
we're all bad fine
looking at it will not reduce the
badness are you following me
let's look where to christ you know why
because by beholding finish my words
if you keep looking at sin that's what
you'll become
i'm calling pornography that's all you
think about look to jesus who never was
it's essential i told you was it last
night the night before when the
israelites were bitten by serpents
numbers 21
god told moses build the serpent of
brass put it on a pole and tell them we
look at the serpent not at the snake
bite
look at jesus how do we look we study
his life
how was he able to resist the
temptations of of lucifer
satan after it fasted 40 days 40 nights
the devil did not come after the first
day of fasting he came after 40.
certainly strategic in how he comes at
you how did christ survive
it is written
satan changed temptations christ kept
his same method of response it is
written he changed temptation again
christ never changed his response it is
written the devil got tired he left to
get a break
because the word of god will make him
dizzy
my listening friend
salvation is a gift
it's a living gift
and that gift literally
is christ
he offers that to you tonight and he
asks you
take your eyes
off your sins
he isn't saying
ignore the fact that you're a sinner
he's simply saying
look at me
and if you look at me
you'll see hope
you'll see possibilities
you'll see victory
look at me and when you look at me
there's something you will not see and
that is sin
my brothers and my sisters
will you not stay with me tonight father
help me to look
and look
and look at my sinless savior can i see
your right hand ah god bless you bow
your heads with me father we thank you
for your word
we thank you for the gift of salvation
and that gift is a man called christ
who's also god it is a gift father
beyond measurement with respect to its
cost we cannot measure the cost we just
accept it by faith it is this gift that
will qualify us for a place in your
kingdom it is this gift that will be the
life we live in the world made new
wherein dwelleth righteousness father
help us to take our eyes off this
addiction and that addiction and look at
the source of power look at the source
of victory look at the man who is god
who can deliver us from every form of
bondage
thank you dear god for your stubborn
love
your stubborn love dear god because
you're not willing that any should
perish
give us a new tonight
the mind of christ
connect us closer to your divine nature
connect us closer to your holiness
save us when you come i pray in jesus
name let god's people say amen and amen
[Music]
you